M3GAN's "killer dance moves" may
have captivated all of the internet,
but the quirky scene wasn't included
in the original script. Here's why
director Gerard Johnstone chose to sneak in the
made-for-viral moment into the final cut of M3GAN.
Released in January 2023, M3GAN
tells the story of a robotics
engineer who uses a lifelike artificial
intelligence doll to befriend her niece,
only for the doll to get carried away with
its overprotective nature, embarking on a
killing spree. With an engaging premise, relevant
commentary on our relationship with technology,
and horror master James Wan co-writing
the story and acting as a producer, M3GAN
garnered a good amount of hype from movie fans
who expected nothing less than a campy good time.
"What are you?"
"I'm M3GAN."
As exciting as the premise is and the talent
involved, what really got people interested
is a viral moment that has dominated social
media for months. A key moment from the film's
trailer received the most attention, going on
to practically define the film. The marketing
for M3GAN features the titular uncanny doll
performing an elaborate dance before killing
her next victim. The dance became an online
sensation, spreading throughout social media like
wildfire. An instant meme, the dance sequence's
absurdity has taken on a life of its own.
It may seem that the now-iconic moment is nothing
more but a hilariously out-of-place moment in an
otherwise seemingly serious film, but director
Gerard Johnstone and the team behind the Blumhouse
pic are more into the joke than audiences might
expect. Busting a move before committing murder
may not be a traditional horror scene, but
it was nevertheless an idea that the team
behind M3GAN chose to run with. The widespread
appeal of the quirky moment has not only helped
further spread the word of the horror film,
but has thoroughly pleased all those involved.
In an interview with toofab, director
Johnstone admitted that he "just kind
of snuck" the scene into the film and is glad that
it went over so well with audiences.
Johnstone explained to the outlet:
While speaking with Insider, screenwriter
Akela Cooper praised Johnstone for adding
value to M3GAN's terrifying nature by
adding the dance sequence. Cooper said:
Allison Williams, who both stars in and executive
produced the film, told Entertainment Weekly that
the team had their own strategy to make the dance
scene a viral sensation. Williams told the outlet:
Marketing M3GAN with the dance sequence clearly
paid dividends as the film went on to make a
whopping $30 million domestically during its
opening weekend. How much of M3GAN's box office
glory can be attributed to the viral nature of
the dance sequence? It's hard to quantify but
take to social media and viewers will find
thousands of memes and fancams of M3GAN,
with the dance sequence dominating the
conversation. It's hard imagining the
buzz surrounding the film being so loud if
the dance sequence wasn't in the trailer.
While speaking with The Hollywood Reporter,
Allison Williams admitted that the film's
creatives were unsure if the moment
deserved to be in the trailer, revealing,
Now that the film has already become one
of the most iconic offerings of 2023,
Williams is grateful that the
moment was kept in the film's
marketing to preach the chaos of M3GAN.
Williams told The Hollywood Reporter,